si elle n'est pas de droit la
vaccination de l'obligation de fait ils
pourraient pu prendre le train vous ne
pourrez plus à le restaurant ne pouvait
être plus lente à de vivre la vie est
terminée si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
donc il faut bien comprendre et signe
que malgré tout la logorrhée qu'on a pu
entendre
nous sommes passés à une vaccination
obligatoire des français qui pose
beaucoup de questions sur le plan de
l'éthique notamment parce que nous
sommes ici aussi dans une dans une
situation sanitaire qui fait qu'un axe
inacio reste sous une autorisation
d'autorisation de commandes de
vaccination qui est conditionnel pardon
il ya beaucoup de français qui sont
inquiets quant aux conséquences sur le
long terme des différents vaccins qui ne
voulaient pas particulièrement
destructeur vacciner parce que il
faisait la balance en langage risque et
cette balance il revenait plutôt positif
quant à ne pas se faire vacciner et ils
sont malgré tout obligé ont pratiquement
la corde au cou que d'aller se faire
vacciner je pense notamment aux jeunes
quand on regarde en réalité les chiffres
faut arrêter de dire n'importe quoi mais
quand on regarde les chiffres
si des personnes vulnérables et les
personnes âgées sont vaccinés les taux
de spa ti hospitalisation dans les pays
où le variant delta est arrivé donc
augmenter à partir du moment où les
personnes qui étaient celles qui
saturaient les hôpitaux italiens les
personnes qui ont des comorbidités et
les personnes âgées sont vaccinés vous
n'avez plus de saturation d'hôpitaux et
donc le fait de vacciner les plus jeunes
ou les personnes qui sont enceintes ou
les personnes qui sont pas les premiers
concernés par la mortalité de ce virus
revient finalement simplement à leurs
obligés de l'acsi nation qui n'est pas
en réalité nécessaire pour hélas apporte
une véritable atteinte à la liberté
vaccinale et on verra ce que dira le
conseil constitutionnel suite au vote de
la loi qui doit intervenir fin juillet
mais je pense que tout cela était
préparée d'avancé que le parlement sera
suivie